hey youtubers it's Charlie so we got to
talk about Aquaman plot teaser and I got
a Green Lantern story that will blow
your mind the really cool things it is
I'm uploading this video January 29th is
actually Aquaman's birthday in the
comics not Jason Momoa the character
Aquaman's birthday so there is a new
round of the injustice to give away I'm
giving away a copy of the game or you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave an Aquaman related comment on this
video be sure to click that Bell to
enable alert so that you don't miss
anything so a whole bunch of Aquaman
stuff is happening this year if they
tease that they just got together with
James Wan to start reading the script
you have ocean master Mira and Aquaman
himself so they're like slowly ramping
up to actually start rolling footage
they just finished Justice League
there'll be a lot of Aquaman and that
Mira is also going to be featured during
Justice League so we'll have a brief
into that movie Jason Momoa has been
doing all kinds of interviews for other
projects he's working on hyping it up he
let out but he's been keeping Aquaman
secret the fact that he was going to be
Aquaman for five years
last time you were here you weren't
allowed to say you're Aquaman but you
were oh and are you wearing an awkward
I'm wearing Aquaman Aquaman well how
would you do it i would never guess
you'd be Aquaman you don't look like the
old cartoon of Aquaman for sure but how
long did you have to keep it quiet I was
like four or five years that long that
long
why how why because they just wanted to
be a secret and people did you tell like
confidentially well now I told all my
friends that I don't I wouldn't say
anything but I I'm really about a figure
so this is where we get to Green Lantern
DC EU stuff because if you back date
that he found out that he was going to
be Aquaman before the original Green
Lantern movie came out so you can
imagine that that was actually supposed
to set up the DCE you the original DC EU
so I'll address that at the end of this
video because that original Green
Lantern universe would have been so
different than the one today but the
plot teaser stuff goes into Geoff Johns
who is now like mister DC movies and
Aquaman stuff that he was writing
couple years ago in the poster that they
dropped last year when they teased
Aquaman was coming to the movies so the
big thing is is they released this
poster previously called unite to 7 when
they revealed what Aquaman was going to
look like during Justice League at least
without his full armor on
since then we've got pictures of what he
looks like with his Atlantean armor so
at some point in the movie he'll get
that but we don't know exactly where he
is when we pick up with them when Bruce
is meeting with him here in this trailer
it does not sound like he's king of
Atlantis in the way they explained his
relationship to Meera
in the movie they're not together
they're not married so this is a very
pre king of Atlantis Aquaman
so part of the movie is Jason Momoa
explains it is explaining where
Aquaman's been where is that right now
in where he's headed in the future the
cool thing is that that teaser poster
gives us an idea for what the plot of
the movie is going to be uniting the
Seven Kingdoms of the nation of Atlantis
if you haven't read the comics Aquaman
is the king of Atlantis this big
undersea city is this ancient culture
but the thing is is that there's the
city of Atlantis then there is the
United Nations of Atlantis and there are
seven kingdoms below the ocean we only
know about three of them as of the new
52 it was this big storyline the Geoff
Johns was teasing called rise of the
seven seas that he was going to be doing
before they did rebirth
now he's teased that he's writing a dr.
Manhattan comic so they neither
postponed that rise of the seven seas or
they're doing something else or they're
not doing it anymore but it was going to
be a big Justice League story about the
return of these missing Atlantean
kingdoms so that might be part of what
happens during the Aquaman movie they
called a movie something of a
swashbuckling adventure so imagine it
moving like one of the Pirates movies
from that franchise only using DC
characters with a much stronger story
with some deeper mythology you don't
have to read the comics but I think next
to the flash movie it's going to be one
of the most fun
DC Comics movies but Aquaman is the most
hardcore member next to Batman in
Justice League so you have to imagine
he's going to dominate through two and a
half hours of that movie
and I imagine that he and Mira will be
together by the end of that like they
know each other in Justice League but
she doesn't really like him that much
they get to know each other then they do
the Lois and Clark thing through the
Aquaman movie the rise of the Seven
Kingdoms storyline is pretty cool it
involves the return of the original king
of Atlantis the one who actually created
Atlantis but it involves this really big
twist with Aquaman's backstory that
recontextualizes everything he knows
about his people in his origins so
originally he thinks he's the son of
Atlin the first king of the United seven
nations of Atlantis so he has this open
borders policy there are isolationists
within his government led by his brother
who staged a coup try to kill him kill
his wife he escapes
so at land using special magic forms
this special trident that he then uses
to sink atlantis in an act of revenge
against his brother in the people that
killed his family aquaman learns to his
horror that he's actually the son of the
king's brother
oren who effectively makes him one of
the villains of this other King story in
present day at land comes back from the
dead they call him the dead King because
he's been dead this whole time so he
rises up and seeks to finish his revenge
against Atlantis but they explain when
he sunk all seven kingdoms of Atlantis
that only three survived including the
city of Atlantis the trench which is the
group of people that live inside the
Marianas Trench it's basically a bunch
of monsters in ends Ebel the other four
are missing they tease that they're
coming back during the rise of the seven
seas Justice League title but because
that was all happening a couple years
ago that might be part of what the
Aquaman script is part of the big
mythology that they're teasing out
because Geoff Johns is bringing back all
this old continuity from before the new
52 a lot of people felt like these four
missing kingdoms were things that were
dealt with during peter david's run on
Aquaman a long time ago which would be
tritonus Poseidonis venture eeeh and
Fiona nog so you don't totally need to
understand what those other lost
patients are but it's just the idea of
Aquaman healing his peoples
not just the people in the city of
Atlantis so he's uniting the undersea
world in the way that Superman will
eventually unite the surface lands or at
least try to that's like a crazy idea
like even though Superman is the most
amazing superhero ever there's still a
lot of people fighting they're still
villains everywhere so it's the same
deal with Aquaman if you want to learn a
little bit more about the character the
rebirth title is actually really good
too the first issue gives you a really
good idea of the scope of the things
that he deals with you have to imagine
that more of the earth is covered with
water than isn't so the amount of people
that he has to deal with in his kingdom
basically everything under water is much
greater than what happens above water so
what they might also do is incorporate
some of the throne of Atlantis storyline
which is basically him reclaiming the
throne of the city of Atlantis from
ocean master so I know a lot of people
are thinking of Wonder Woman is more of
the Thor of the Justice League
but Aquaman's story seems a little bit
more like what's been happening in the
Thor movies with Loki vs Thor battle for
the throne even though technically Thor
doesn't want it but Aquaman doesn't want
the throne either so if you haven't
already I would recommend that you check
out the throne of Atlantis movie it's
just like the other more recent DC
Comics movies that have come out they
just released Justice League dark I know
a lot of you've asked me to do a story
for it but it doesn't really have
anything to do with what's going on in
the movies right now even though they're
actually developing a live-action
Justice League dark so can we just
imagine what the DC Comics universe
would have looked like originally had
Green Lantern been a success you can
imagine thematically how the storyline
of Manus kills dealt with the idea of
the world reacting to an alien the
original story of Green Lantern became
this big assault on Coast City
so imagine parallax attacks Coast City
there's this big crazy alien attack the
earth learns about the Green Lantern
Corps that then becomes the entry point
not Superman in the way they wrote it -
is really crazy they actually said that
as the ring is coming - Hal Jordan like
searching for a replacement it flies by
Clark Kent in Metropolis meaning that
Superman already existed on that earth
so that was in the greg berlanti script
not in
the rewritten script that actually ended
up making it to screen so a lot of
people always wonder what the original
Green Lantern looked like it was just
way weirder in a good way it had a lot
more Emerald dawn stuff and by the end
of the movie he would have had like the
silver temples like he does in the
comics so there was just a lot more
comic book II stuff in it they ended up
turning it into more of a
paint-by-numbers safe movie like they
didn't want to take any chances with it
and that's part of what led to its
demise along with really bad CG but
that's another story they basically used
Superman is the jumping off point for
the DC Universe alien comes to earth
everyone freaks out then we get Batman V
Superman as the reaction to that moving
it to Justice League and everything else
but it would have been cool if we'd had
Green Lantern to start with so that's
why a lot of people are like okay we
have the Green Lantern Corps movie that
they've just announced it doesn't
necessarily have to link up with the
Justice League movies yet but it sounds
like they're going to be teasing Hal
Jordan during Justice League somewhere
whether or not we actually see him in a
costume or see him on screen but
congratulations to the new injustice
giveaway winner KD flash please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details there
was a new round that started in this
video I'll just announce the winner when
I post new flash tomorrow while you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to learn all about the Green Lantern
Corps movie they just announced you can
click here to learn all about the Super
Bowl trailers that are coming next week
thank you so much for watching everybody
since at 5:00 I'll see you guys in the
next video
you